[Music]
thank you very much for being here
what would the Lib Dem class of 2010
advised the Lib Dem class of 2019 were
to find itself in a similar position
that's the one you were well I think the
advice would be not to go into coalition
with the leaders of the Tory Party or
the Labour Party it's not that I think
2010 was a mistake I think it was partly
brought about inevitably because of
numbers and the circumstances of a major
economic emergency but no I think if it
happened next time there's no way we
could work with Johnson and the present
government I know of these anyway we
could work with Corbin and his people
but if we return to what you could call
normality and some broadly based Tory
party we could probably work with them
certainly with the Labour Party we'd be
more comfortable but not under the
present leadership so will it just
require a change in leadership deeper
than that I mean it's not like carbon as
an individual I'd rather like him
actually their gain gauging and his good
on the lot of liberal issues it's it's
it's the coterie does he surrounded
himself with the hard left movement
momentum come and ease and you know
they've got values that are just not
compatible with ours and then we've had
people joining us a little see on a bird
you who are you know refugees from the
motherlode party and they are now our
MPs so how would you summarize let them
values then I would summarize them as
liberal internationalist
environmentalist a strong social
democratic
Green do you think those values are
under strain if you're accepting and
peace from parties both left and right
well they're potentially uh I mean if we
were indiscriminate you know it could
just become a hodgepodge but though the
people who are joining us people lose
subscribe to those values I mean they
made we may have disagreements on
particular policy issues but I know the
individuals that are quite small numbers
at the moment and I would say they're
entirely compatible with values I think
it would be more difficult if you and if
you reached further into the Tory Party
with me you know Philip Hammond and so
on they broken away but under no stretch
of the imagination would they see
themselves as liberal or social
democratic and would probably be pretty
uncomfortable with us and they're not
asking to join us and similarly there
are limits on the labor side too and
then there are potential refugees from
the Labour Party who you know may well
have supported Breck seeds you know who
just fundamentally disagree with us but
the group that we've got so far we're
very comfortable with do you think they
should have to face a by-election no I
don't think it's necessary though the
the you know they will argue that the
party that they joined and stood for no
longer represents you know what's
currently going on so I mean we're in a
rapidly moving situation I'm not sure it
would help anybody to have string of
by-elections and they will be tested and
you know it will be difficult for them
to defend their seats they'll be
standing against official labourers and
conservatives in some cases and that
we'll be testing enough without the
necessity of by-elections are there any
conditions under which you form a
coalition
with Corbin's labor I find it impossible
to think of any I can conceive of a
emergency governments and government of
national unity of whatever want to call
it that would almost certainly have to
be headed up by somebody who was broadly
consensual not that's not a tribal
figure I mean the obvious names on the
Tory side of people that came Clark on
the labor side Harriet Harman Hilary
Benn and people like that in which you
know the the Corbin Labor Party would
presumably get behind but I can't
envisage as falling in behind you know
covered no the party would you ever
consider I haven't been asked resource
I suspect they would go through a Lib
Dem to lead it because we are very much
on one side of the argument of they
probably want consensual figure but if I
was asked to work in it and support it
of course I would mr. Linton's policy
moving which has been to move to revoke
article 50 a direct response to labor
pivoting to a second referendum
well the Labour Party hasn't really
pivoted I mean I think we may have
anticipated that they would the current
position as I understand it is that they
would support a referendum after labour
has tried to negotiate a brexit deal and
they're not committed to remain as
opposed to whatever rec seat option is
on offer which is very very far from our
position I mean the the idea of
supporting revoke isn't new I mean we
did vote for revoke when it was put upon
with the
aaseesh nationalists and some labor
people and others but you know we're now
arguing the in the very very particular
circumstance where we win an overall
majority yeah I mean I you know I'd like
to believe it but it's a stretch getting
from 18 to 320 but you know that's a
part when we're fighting for the
people's vote that's that's the basis of
our policy you an economist by trade
before you enter politics broadly yes I
talked economics and I was chief
economist at Shell for a while well I
started dabbling in politics
I was labor initially in Glasgow in the
60s
I taught economics in the morning and
practiced it in the afternoon in Glasgow
City Chambers and I was a counselor
there was a certain irony because I used
to in the morning teach the economics of
Adam Smith and markets and then in the
afternoon practice rent control so yeah
I was living with rather contradictory
ideas as inevitably you do in politics
but I've always been fascinated by where
politics and economics overlap and
contradict each other and so sort of
it's an interesting problem I have to
I've got a book coming out shortly about
the economics of politics and the
politics of economics and you're
standing down as an MP at the next
election
what are you glad to have achieved and
what are you sad not to have a Gina
well I think the positives are getting
our party from a very dire position not
2017 we were close to extinction
I was probably overstating it but it was
in a pretty bad way to a position where
we're now a serious challenger in
aggregate terms for about seven percent
in polls 223 or happened on the my
leadership so I'm pleased with that and
I'm pleased a lot of the things I did
there's cabinet minister in the
coalition I did I did a legacy of a lot
of very practical things around
industrial strategy setting up banks to
support small business and the
environments you know social reforms
flexible working supporting research and
innovation did a lot of useful legacy
things so I'm quite proud of that period
you know we had problems with some of
the tory policies at the same time in
terms of what I didn't achieve well I
suppose I was disappointed that at the
end of five years in government I got
thrown out of Parliament you know that
was a bit bit would come down but I got
back in again no I I think if I have a
regret it's probably not being there
sooner I mean I could have there was an
outside possibility I could have become
leader of the party in 2007 2008 I had
quite a high profile at the time because
of the financial crisis and would have
probably taken the party in a different
direction and a bit of regret around
that where would you have taken it well
it would have been much more
identifiably a social democratic party
we might well find ourselves in
coalition but I think the relationship
would have been different
and we would have maintained our
distinct identity I think difficult I
mean they Claire did some good things
but I think I did diverge with him
somewhat on economic policy and some of
the things the coalition did do you find
it
concerning to leave behind a lived in
party with someone like Phillip Lee in
it no not at all I mean I've had enough
in Italy well but I have met him a few
times he was actually one of the
earliest Tories to come out publicly
criticizing their exit policy was quite
brave to do so so I you know I have no
problems with Phillip um and there may
be things I don't know about but what
I've seen it been they say it was a good
good guy because there's there must be
more - there is more - Lib Dems than
exit policy only and Philly's stances on
same-sex marriage and some proposals
he's made towards migrants coming to the
UK having to prove that they don't have
HIV seem to clash quite strongly with
the core ideals of well on the same-sex
marriage my producer said of course is
famously had difficulties with our
policy on gay marriage I don't have
problems and vast majority of Liberal
Democrats are actively promoted it we
you know we thought like to think it was
our idea that but it's unfortunate that
he did on the wider range of policies
that I have seen he he is a good liberal
where he's diverged from us in the past
I think he has accepted that you know he
was wrong
have you read David Cameron's
autobiography I haven't read it yet I
haven't read the reports of it well I
mean I think what I find interesting and
a bit frustrating is that you know
because of this defining decision to
have the referendum with such disastrous
consequences essentially the the
biography seems to be is only about that
trying to justify himself whereas
actually he's five years running the
coalition she what she did very well I'm
and I didn't
with him a lot of things but he was a
very good chairman of the cabinet that
always got a bit glossed over do you
think he's guilty of arrogance well I
think yes I think to a degree that was a
kind of assumption that it was this kind
of traditional Tory thing about being
born to rule and sort of feeling of
infallibility and lack of self-criticism
which i think is very much part of their
culture it used to be and he had it and
I think he it was only when he'd made
this absolutely catastrophic mistake
that he has been forced to be a bit more
self-critical why why politicians
concerned with legacy do you think like
that personal legacy well I think we all
like to feel we've made a difference
we've done something useful with our
lives I mean at the very basic level I
suppose it's same as every human being I
like to feel with a company something
whether it's with our families or our
parties or our professions I'm not
obsessed by 9 I think you know there is
there is a good legacy but I know
doesn't worry me that keeps some people
don't think otherwise
I have written a memoir of which is
actually before I got into the
government and I didn't write it in
order to justify what I was doing in
politics it was more about my early life
and it was trying to communicate to
people the kind of background - you know
why sunday like me finds their way into
politics and it was
that my tarted it wasn't written in the
kind of spirits of Cameron or before
that some of the big giants of politics
who you know just tried to justify their
decisions in the cabinet
I suppose the role models would be the
college names just gone that the postman
Alan Johnson yes I thought that was the
perfect political biography
autobiography and I suppose you know in
a way I was trying to trying to emulate
in that style and after standing down as
MP for trickling will it be more writing
what do you have I'm not sure I mean I'm
writing books and I've got some
commissions to write a couple of books I
[Music]
do quite a lot of dancing in my spare
time and I want to do tournaments I've
done them before not very well but I'm
trying to get to a higher standard and I
may be spending more time at festivals
like this okay thank you for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you